I have my axis of rotation. It's negative X, Z. It's a good idea to normalize
this, but this will do for now. If I look at my cube, it's pretty easy to figure
out the diagonal directions themselves. Here is the easiest one. It goes from
negative one, negative one, negative one to one, one, one. So the cylinder's
axis is (2,2,2). We can also this vector's length to find the distance from one
corner to another. These are the facts we need to continue. We've got the axis
of rotation. We need the angle to rotate and the length of the cylinder itself.
Here's three JS code that computes the cylinder's length. Three JS uses a class
called Vector3. What you put in a vector 3 a point or a vectors coordinate is up
to you. Perhaps a better name might have been coordinate 3 but that' pretty
bulky most graphic systems you'll encounter will call coordinates vectors but
it's easy enough to understand from the context what is meant. To find the
cylinders axis direction and length I set up the 2 corner locations I then
subtract one vector from the other using the sub vectors method. Giving a vector
from one point to another. There are a huge number of vector and matrix
operations supported in 3JS, subtraction is just one of many. Once we have the
cylinder axis, this last line of code computes the length of this axis, which
we'll need for knowing how long to make the cylinder. At this point, we have the
axis of rotation The length of the cylinder, but we don't have the angle of
rotation yet. However, we have everything we need to get it. Given this
cylinder's access, we can dot product it with the y axis, which is where the
cylinder starts at, and then, by the dot product of that and its final
position... We will get the angle that we need to rotate. Remember that the dot
product computes the cosine of the angle between two normalized vectors. So we
normalize the cylinder's axis here and takes its dot product with the y axis
vector here. This gives us the cosine of the angle. So we take the arc cosine to
get the angle back in radiants. Using a dot product is a bit of overkill, by the
way. Computing a dot product with a y axis like this is the same as just
grabbing the y component of the cylAxis. We could've simply normalized and done
this like this code here. However, unless this is a critical loop, like we're
making a billion of these ornaments, I'd recommend using this first way. If
someone reads or modifies this code in the future, the intent is clearer and
more general. Now we have all the facts we need to make this object, the axis
and angle of rotation and the length of the cylinder. So let's get cracking.
Well, I guess I should mention that the sign of the theta might be a little bit
questionable here. We could use the right had rule to make sure we have the
direction of rotation right. Or we could use the principle of negate and try
again. I learned about this practice long ago from an article in an old trade
journal called SGI Insider. It was great to realize that someone else was doing
what I also do. If I put a rotation in and it goes the wrong direction, just try
the opposite. So feel free to do the same, as you're in good company. You could
spend 15 minutes trying to figure out the sign needed after some set of matrix
operations, and still have about a 50 percent chance of getting it right.
Faster, more reliable is just to try it and see. That said, this practice won't
help much if there are too many things to negate or if the rotation is part of a
long chain of transforms. Or if you're starting from an incorrect algorithm.
But, if you're feeling the math is solid, go ahead and just do it. Using this
principle with my test program, I found I needed to negate the angle to move the
rod to the correct place. I guess I could've thought it through and realized
this is the right-hand rule, and all that kind of stuff, but nonetheless, just
trying it made me realize we need to. To have a negative theta. I don't really
like negative angles, I like to think positively, so I negated both the angle
and the axis direction. This should give exactly the same rotation. If you
rotate clockwise around one axis, rotating counter clockwise around the opposite
axis' direction is the same thing.